uh you guys have to see this uh for a
very brief period of time
it started to maybe look like donald
trump would consider
conceding to joe biden accepting that he
lost
to joe biden we heard that melania and
jared kushner were supposedly telling
donald trump you might want to look at
conceding this seems to have done a 180
yesterday
with some absurd triggered tweets from
donald trump
claiming that he won essentially all of
the key battleground
states for this election trump also sent
out his press secretary kaylee mckennany
as well as rnc chair ronna mcdaniel plus
a lawyer
to some room in a hotel to claim that
the fight will continue for a long time
we'll talk about that a little bit later
it's starting to be beyond belief that
this is even happening but take a look
at these tweets trump first tweeting
about nevada
saying nevada is turning out to be a
cesspool of
fake votes uh m schlapp and adam laxalt
are finding things that when released
will be absolutely shocking now that
tweet was flagged
as misinformation by twitter joe biden
is currently winning in nevada by
36 000 votes that's about three percent
it's not even in recount territory in
nevada
trump then goes on to wisconsin trump
tweeting quote wisconsin is looking very
good
needs a little time statutorily will
happen
soon trump claiming i guess that he's
going to win wisconsin now
the margin in wisconsin is about 20 000
votes
this is the same margin by which donald
trump won in 2016
he didn't complain then but now he's
complaining
then donald trump goes on to
pennsylvania tweeting quote pennsylvania
prevented us from watching much of the
ballot count
unthinkable and illegal in this country
now
twitter also flagged that as
disinformation the lead in pennsylvania
for joe biden has grown to 45 000 votes
and both republican and democratic poll
watchers
were allowed to oversee trump is lying
and then trump going on to georgia
saying quote
georgia will be a big presidential win
as it was the night of the election now
as of this moment
georgia has not been called but biden's
lead there has grown to 12 000 votes now
as i said earlier on in the program
there's no doubt
that these are thin margins in some
states
mostly still larger margins than trump
had in 2016
but this is delusional and
completely humiliating at this point
donald
trump uh claiming he's going to win
states
he didn't win when how what and if you
actually
ask as we saw in the press conference
yesterday with
kaylee mckenney if you actually say do
you have
proof of specific fraudulent or
illegal votes the answer is not yes
they go off into well we weren't given
access
and well then why are you suspecting
that that happened
well we just need to let the courts play
well but why do courts need to be
involved if you don't actually have
evidence yet a lot of that came up
during this gong show press conference
with kaylee mckennany which was so
pathetic and lie riddled that even fox
news had to cut away
let's discuss that next and then later
we'll get we'll get into the
growing fury that the current president
the last gasp president has with fox
news
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll
look like you spent a lot more all of
their watches are made in small batches
from
top quality materials and they just look
great i went on their site and picked
out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 percent off everything in
their store when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch and i've put that link right
underneath this video